foreign
Nathan in Oklahoma City how are you
I'm doing well how are you Dave better
than I deserve what's up
well just got a question for you so I'm
28 years old and I just did baby step
seven about seven months ago boom wow
thank you and I'm currently like
rebuilding my emergency and stuff
because I deleted my accounts for being
debt free
and I'm just kind of curious where to go
now because I'm kind of lost with the
whole like where to invest my money
um right now what accounts did you do
hold on what what accounts did you
delete
well I'm not like my checking and my
savings like I cleared them all so I
could be that free pay off the house and
now that I'm 100 debt free I've got my
six months emergency saved and now I am
investing in my
um well I have two Roth accounts one
through work and then a rough uh Ira
good and then I and then I do uh ten
percent my tsp
um
and apart from that
um I'm just you know kind of saving
money and living living life every day
really but I need a goal and my goal is
to get more money but that seems really
kind of boring
honestly I mean just to do it that way
and I'm not 100 sure if that's doing the
right thing
Nathan you're in danger
okay you're in danger of messing all
this up
gotcha because the fastest way to get
rich is boring
and if you go screwing around with get
rich quick trying to be cool
you're going to lose all of the progress
you have made
and and you got you know one of the
things I ran into when I first started
coaching wealthy people years ago was
they had this latent guilt like I've got
two million dollars but I don't feel
like I'm doing it right
like there must be something
sophisticated these smart people are
doing stuff I don't know how to do and
they're the ones with the two million
dollars and they're doing very
simplistic primitive basic things
and they got wealthy but they you know
they certainly did not buy crypto
right right you know they certainly are
not doing nothing down Tic Tac real
estate
you know they're they're not trying to
get rich quick they're not trying to do
a double uh a double helix backflip
Family Partnership that they read about
on Instagram
because it's a sure-fired way to lose
your butts what it is you know I mean
come on yeah so just put just slow you
know tortoise The Tortoise and the hair
the hair was the sexy cool one he lost
the race
the tortoise was ugly
and steady
and predictable
and boring
please be boring well now Dave all of us
tortoises don't have to be ugly now
you done got personal Dave
well yeah no and and seriously but the
uh I mean the the point being the plan
yeah is all all of your smart friends
who are broke but wear clothes they
can't afford to drive cars they can't
afford and go on vacations they can't
afford all of your smart friends will
make fun of your tortoise plans right
that's right but they're the sexy hairs
they're the ones that the the rabbit
that's cool they light all the look you
know they they look like they got it all
together and they got nothing nothing
nada
it's almost like got a headache that's
all I got
it's almost like we want there to be
like this secret of the wealthy that
only a few people can get their hands on
and then I really wanted that because
I'm really smart at math and so I knew
if it was complicated and difficult I
could do it that must be it that I would
be able to do it and so just show me the
complicated double backflip barrel of
Fish Hooks yeah I'll get it I'll be able
to do it pride comes right before the
fall right before it nope any any Joe
can do it you just gotta Be steady
boring
what you can do is you can pay very
close attention to your accounts
and just go okay yeah I'm Gonna Be
steady but I'm also going to make sure
that sucker's maximizing that's right
that is not going to be 80d I'm not
going to take my hand off the wheel hand
off the wheel hand off the wheel I'm
gonna drive straight through but I'm
gonna be very diligent and go okay this
this accounts for this this accounts for
that and I'm I and I'm goal oriented and
those are things that you are Nathan
that are very good and obviously
I was being a little bit traumatic to
make sure you got the message but but
you've done very well now I would also
say in his situation we we recommend
everybody work with a smart investor Pro
or somebody with their Investments but a
guy like him really needs that
accountability to not get like oh the
Market's being weird or I feel like my
guy told me about this thing over here I
need to be trying he's not going to
function in fear he's going to make he's
going to make bad decisions out of greed
[Music]
um
that's why I was stopping him on because
I know that guy because I was him yeah
because I I because I'm smart I don't
this is too slow you know and and that's
that's about the time you're about to
step on it so just look at something